con el panorama que vive Israel Cuáles
son los motivos para la constante
inestabilidad política hay posibilidades
reales de lograr un desbloqueo
Hola un cordial saludo desde Costa Rica
el problema principal al parecer es que
se ha transformado el proceso electoral
en Israel en una especie de referendo
para la continuación o no de Benjamín
etania o la última coalición que fue una
coalición de de minorías Finalmente no
se pudo extender Más allá de un año y
después de una ley que no se votó que
fue pues propuesta porque de onzar
Finalmente se tuvo que disolver el
parlamento y Llamar a las Quintas
elecciones desde el año 2019 lo cual
pues muestra un poco de inestabilidad
para el Estado nuevamente se Proponen
elecciones Y eso ha llevado de nuevo a
netaniado ser uno de los candidatos que
se proyectan como el principal de poder
ganar las las elecciones en esta ocasión
en un sistema que además A diferencia de
latinoamérica pues es un sistema
parlamentario bueno ninguna coalición
alcanzaría la mayoría en la que necesita
realmente se pueden lograr más alianzas
sí Generalmente cuando
termina el proceso electoral el que gana
la mayoría de los votos es el designado
por el presidente dentro de sus
funciones de poder formar coalición que
debería ser una coalición mínima de 61
ya que el parlamento cuenta con 120
diputados poder lograr esa minoría o esa
mayoría de digamos básica de 61 escaños
y empezar a gobernar si nadie lo logra o
si no lo logra netaneado pues se le
convoca al segundo digamos que haya
logrado mayoría dentro de la elección y
si es que al final de cuentas no lo
logra se plantea un tiempo determinado
para que se pueda conformar lo que se
llama Un gobierno de minorías que fue lo
que anteriormente naftalí benet del
anterior Primer Ministro logró y que
finalmente por lo heterogéneo del grupo
que lo conformaba terminó Pues
disolviéndose bueno históricamente se
considera que la votación de los árabes
israelíes es clave para definir Quién
gana qué se puede esperar en en esta
ocasión cuando hay un hartazgo
generalizado entre la población
es posible de que a diferencia del
proceso anterior la población árabe en
esta ocasión no vote tan en numeroso
como puede ocurrir con el bloque que
lideraba
Avast anteriormente manzura vas y que en
esta ocasión pues desgraciadamente La
minoría árabe pues no tenga un peso tan
determinante aún así se habla de que en
esta lección han habido un porcentaje
muy alto en general de votantes que
desde el año 1999 no se daba y se espera
de que haya pues mayor afluencia aún así
los resultados empezarán a ver a partir
de las 10 de la noche que cierran las
urnas electorales en Israel Y a partir
de ahí empiezan a hacer los cálculos
para ver finalmente Cuál va a ser la
coalición que eventualmente va a poner
en primer lugar a netaniado Y a partir
de ahí ver si se puede conformar un este
una coalición y finalmente Hay que
llamar a otro proceso electoral más que
es bastante desgastante para una